Hello, And welcome to Felix Wardrobe!
A new series! 20 parts at least!
We got Marzia on the camera!
*Marzia noises*
*Poods realizes what he's doing*
Are you zooming in?
DON'T ZOOM IN :(
(Nice editing. 100% Rotten Tomatoes) 2017 gone wrong
I-I just thought I'll do like a go- why
am I doing this help "cause it's cool" no it's not so
this is my closet.. look at Marzia's closet
A lil' bigger but yeah I don't know maybe
you probably don't care about what
clothes i have but i thought i'll do it
anyway so here we go-Oh welcome to my
closet we got all kinds of stuff where
should we begin this one that's my
that's me underwears okay well up here
we have two I have two underwears left
you have to do laundry Marzia
otherwise I'm going to have to go cowboy
I don't have these which is like I know
why I've saved this you remember how
long I've had this this is one of those
things that's stayed in your wardrobe
along with my underwear probably soaked
up all my ball sweat sorry should I wear
it for the sake of the video well look
you let's check out the next drawer all
my socks yes you can tell neatly
organized I'm a very organized person
moving on do you want to check out my
socks just one all right i'll pick one
my fa- well it's not here well I-
this used to be my favorite pair but now
i only have one of them but it's got
like a little tongue on it you can
always like *insert Felix noises* okay next up we have very
organized as well i didn't clean before
this i know everyone else just cleans
and they're like 'oh oh it just happened
to be like this' well i have all my
watches got my baby g which we got in
japan I'm not really too much into watches
M: Is that why you have 25 million?
Well you have to have
some of them you  know this one it looks
expensive but it's not. it's vivian west
yeah it's probably the nicest one
I have but oh yeah the pulse met one
it's a bit feminine but I like it
anyway I don't know I know some people
they spend a lot of money on like one
watch but for me I'd rather buy a lot of
different watches and then just use them
I.. you get bored of watches and like no
matter how much you love a watch you're
gonna get bored of it. so I'd
rather get different ones. we've got them
pins. If you're cool like me you
gotta have pins always add pins they a
little pug can save an outfit you know
an artist cat can't go wrong with that
we were talking about- is this like the
girl from Bob's burgers? I have a lot of
black caps. Listen they're good , it's
always good hey, a meme good old meme
this one is from lazy oaf I got it for
free i got this one for free and i got
this one for free and i got this one for
free and i got this one for free but you
never know when you need a cap you know
what i mean when you got a bad hair day
not today though. I like them small
That's what she saaaaaid
moving on to my pant collection
it goes look at this boii that's right I
always just wear these pants. these are
from urban black skinny pants you can't
go wrong with that especially when you
got legs like these you know what I mean?
looks really nice on the butt as well, or
does it? I don't know actually, did you
just zoom in on my butt? I have this pair
of blacks as well but Edgar this is all
Edgar, it just soaks up Edgar, I can't wear them
got a nice pair of sweatpants from KUF (??)
it's always good to have like a nice
pair just uh, you feeling lazy just throw
them on fashion can go with any outfit
adidas sweat pants as well they look
like proper nice pants but really they're
just fucking sweatpants got a cool
little back pocket very Japanese I think
with my style a lot of it is like
Japanese
or Asian or korean fashion or whatever
I'm probably wrong am I I don't know I
don't know what I'm talking about it's
not like I know anything about these
things oh yeah and I have these as well
they're so weird like snowboard fabric
or whatever like this weird fabric but
they're so comfortable moving on to my
shirts which I never wear this one is cool
I got it recently got the same problem
with fucking Edgar everywhere on it and
it's ethical I care about ethical
clothing. Marzia  you told me like about
ethical clothing or whatever so I don't
ninety percent isn't but if you have one
piece that is you feel like I made a
positive impact on the world oh yeah
this jacket it's so cool finally it's
summer and I can wear it properly it's
from one of my favorite brands Heresy
Heresy?  Her"say"?  *Heresy*  but it's white
like it's begging to just get destroyed
having a white jacket. It's got this cool back
HE HE HERESY *Heresy* I really like
it it's really dope really cool so now it's
getting hot out i can finally wear stuff
like this I don't know, is this still
cool it's like a new season now like I
feel like I need to update but this is
from raised by wolves, it's a Canadian
brand streetwear cool stuff I really
like it you wear like a maybe like a
long sleeve underneath I think that
looks really cool same with this one I
love this one it's so stupid and weird
but awesome at the same time from Vinti
Andrews I mean it's got Birds on it
its way over-sized I guess this
is , it's supposed to be like a dad shirt in a
way but it looks fucking cool and I love
the fabric I've literally never washed
it
it's like it's that kind of, does that sound
weird? it's that kind of fabric
all right don't judge me what else do we
got in here oh my weed, my stash
let's not look into that boy
I've been looking for this ,top, top of the
morning to you laddies, a lot of people have been
asking about this one because it's so
cool it's Heresy again and they I think
they're like to two guys that used to be
like illustrators and then they
wanted to make a fashion brand and I
think that's you can tell like they make
cool designs like like this that you
wouldn't normally see I think they have
their vision I like it it's very cool you
probably tell i really like like
long-sleeve shirt I think it looks good
this one is from Katya Krasnova
she's a really cool like she's a
tattoo artist and she does like she
does her own Merch, this is too small for me
you should have it Marzia
You want it? good catch
oh my god that's all my shirts my t-shirts gotta
I have to constantly like sell stuff
because I can never fit stuff in here so we
sell whatever i have extra I sell on
depop for charity so it's always like
maxed out and it's like oh yeah I'm not
wearing that I gotta replace it but
some of my favorite here here's another
one it's also from Vinti Andrews a lot
of you guys complimented on this one
America it's like a double layer shirt
it's really cool I love oversized type
of clothing yeah and I got tis one
from lazy oaf they dont sell it anymore
yeah this is from don't hug me i'm
scared and they dont sell it anymore i'm
really glad i got one got this one from
inu inu they sell like really weird
japanese style you got a rep team sesh
oh yeah so wrinkly I haven't been
wearing t-shirts for a while don't judge
me okay this one of some doomsday is a
British brand i really recommend
checking them out i think they're really
cool they do like cool prints they're
sort of like tattoo inspired i think a
lot of if I had to to describe my closet it's
like Japan, Sweden, tattoo ,wannabe hipster
there's too much to show let's move on to
the sweater good ol oversized hoodie
Thank You siren they come and get me
this one my mom bought for me it's so
embarrassing yeah but it's really cool I
don't think she knew it was from sadboys
which is like Yung Lean's rap group he's
got a cool style I was like good job mom
you're actually cool that she was like
yeah I knew it was sadboys it's cool i
really like it this sweater is so
fucking cool you got me this one it's
raised by wolf again i want to get more
from them but they're from Canada and I
just had to pay taxes every time I buy
from them it's just not worth raised by
wolf hook me up please okay a lot of
just hoodies everyone is always like oh
he's always just wearing Stussy all right
I have two Stussy hoodies and I
needed hoodies and they have cool
hoodies okay I'm not sponsored please
sponsor me Stussy please I have two okay
calm down I have two there's two of them
and a couple pants and a t-shirt and a
belt whatever this one I got in LA it's
so cool
I never get to wear it I never wear it
the guy that sold it to me I really like
because I didn't know the brand of this
sweater and he was like oh so you don't
know the brand and I was like no and
he's like you sir are an awesome person
and I'm like thank you I'll buy this
sweater he was wearing it too so I felt
like a little copycat but whatever
another from the man this is your
favorite Vinti Andrews again he makes
such fucking cool stuff it's it's so
oversized t it's ridiculous like if you
wear it the first time you feel stupid
but it's so cool when you wear it I love
this sweater ill never sell it like
this sweater so I don't know now I know
what you're thinking hey Felix how do
you look outside well I know a lot of
people are going to hate on me but I
where a man purse and I'm proud okay
what up I got all kinds of shit here
wallet dog toy vape juice got my okay pin got
my tarot cards for no reason Skeletor
let's put Skeletor on that bitch yes so
when we were in Japan I noticed all the
guys was wearing their bags like this
like it's a thing apparently so this is
from Japan porters yeah Tokyo Japan I
love it it's so convenient if you're a
guy no shame okay no shame in a purse
and all the way all you can always just
slide it over you know and you're like
yeah I this is the most expensive thing
I have it was like 800 pounds yeah
it's probably not worth it but I just I
really liked it said John on it my name
is John cool bag is a cool jacket I had
to get it okay I always just wear these
I really just have one pair of shoes
they're nike huaraches a lot of people
don't like these I don't know why I
think they're so cool I've had other
shoes that are way nicer but there's
just so easy to put on it i'm not going
to bother putting on other shoes this
has been fashion school with Felix Pewdiepie
if you need any fashion tips just
let me know at any time you know I've
know pretty much everything I'll link
to whatever I use down here I have
no idea if this is entertaining or anyone
gives a shit i hope I don't seem like I'm
trying to like I know anything about
anything it's just I didn't really used
to care about dressing up at all for
like a very like my whole life and then
i think i think when i got my tattoo I
was like yeah it's kind of nice to
present yourself in a way does that make
sense that's it let me know if you
enjoyed leave a like or whatever and
brofist